عاده ما ينظر الى الاشخاص الجذابين على
انهم اكثر ذكاءه وثقه بانفسهم
وفي كل الاحوال
في كل الاحوال العلم طريق الى العلاقه بين
الجمال والجاذبيه والنفسيه والان دراسه
جديده حاولت ترصد فاذا كانت الجاذبيه يمكن
ان تؤثر على السلوك الفرد وتوصلت الى
الاشخاص الذين يرون انفسهم جذابين اكثر رد
عليه تصرف بانانيه وجد الباحثون من جامعه
جنوب الصين ان المشاركين في الدراسه الذين
قيموا مظهرهم هم بدرجه
للتصرف من اجل مصلحتهم الخاصه ويشعرون
بانهم اكثر استحقاقا لمعامله خاصه
المزيد عن الجاذبيه والانانيه من عاصمه من
اشهر عواصم الجمال بيت بازاري من باريس
[تصفيق]
كلمه نسمعها نفهمها ونعيشها واقعه في
المكان والزمان ولكن ماذا عن الانسان
[موسيقى]
العلاقه بين الجمال او الجاذبيه وبين
النفسيه موضوع شائقا
واليوم خمس دراسات
اجري فين امريكيين وطلاب صينيين
[موسيقى]
او على الاقل الذي لا يعتقدون انهم كذابون
وصلت حدث اليوم من عاصمه من اشهر عواصم
الجمال عن ظاهره او متلازمه في علم النفس
وهي مبدا الجميل جيد يعني انك اذا شاهدت
شخصا جميلا ستكون
بان صفاته الانسانيه جيده وانه صادقا ومحب
وطبعا لا علاقه للجمل بذلك الدراسات ايضا
حسنا
يتمتعون بتميز لصالحهم في العمل من قبل
المديرين وفي الدراسه من قبل المدرسين
حتى في التحالفات المهنيه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
وفي النهايه الجمال هبه ثمينه فهل تتحول
بالنسبه لصاحبها سببا للانانيه وللاعتقاد
بانه يحق له ما لا يحق لغيره الخطر موجود
لكن الجمال يبقى الجمال ليث بزاري باريس
من عاصمه النور الى الرياض ينضم الينا
لنفسي دكتور اسامه النعيمي دكتور اسعد
صباحك هل فعلا الاكثر جاذبيه هم الاكثر
انانيه
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادين صباح
الخير على العربيه المشاهدين مستمعين صباح
الخير على الغائب الحاضر استاذ عادل اكثر
الناس جاذبيه واقلهم انانيه والله نورت
الشاشه يا شيخنا اما بالنسبه لموضوع
السؤال لو رجعتي الى حوالي عشر سنوات
سابقا في 2011 كانت اصل هذه الدراسه اجريت
على الرجال فقط واختاروا شخصيتين جميلتين
كريستيانو رونالدو وجورج كلوني لكن بعدين
اضافه لهم وقالوا انه الجمال بهذا الشكل
هو قصدهم الجاذبيه الخارجيه الاشخاص قد
تكون مدعات للثقه المفرطه بالنفس فتجعل
اشخاص يشعروا انهم يستطيعوا ان يقوموا
باشياء لا يستطيع الاخرين القيام بها وهذه
اللي احنا نترجمها على القدره المفرطه على
السيطره على الاخرين فهذا اللي خلها هؤلاء
الاشخاص عندهم شعور انهم يستحقوا اشياء لا
يستحقها الاخرين اللي حضرتك سميتها
انانيه يعني دكتور اسامه بهاي الحاله ليش
احنا عم نبالغ وصلنا الموضوع لانانيه يعني
لما شخص يشعر انه مميز ولافت للنظر طبيعي
انه يحس حاله يستحق الاهتمام اليس كذلك
المقارنه بين الموضوعين انه في الدراسه
الاولى اللي بدات في 2011 كانت الناس تنظر
الى الاشخاص هؤلاء على انهم جذونون
الدراسه الحاليه صارت قناعه الاشخاص
بانفسهم انهم جذابون يعني يمكن الحواليس
يقولوا لها يعني توكل على الله انت ما
عندك اي شيء من الجاذبيه لكن هم شعورهم
الداخلي انهم جذابون خلي عندهم ثقه مفرطه
بالنفس واشعارهم انهم ما يستحقوا اشياء قد
لا يكون يستحقونها لكن هذا مو معناها انهم
مخطئون بالعكس هذا تدريب نفسي جميل جدا ان
يشعر الانسان ان هو يستحق اشياء قد يكون
الاخرين يظنون انه لا يستحق هذا الشيء
لطيف جدا طب لكن هل يا دكتور هل جاذبيه
تؤثر على سلوك الفرد ونجاحته
اكيد اكيد شعور الانسان انه هو متميز عن
الاخرين يعطيه شيء من
القدره على ان يسيطر على الاخرين يعطيه
شعور فطري وهذا الشيء فطري ايضا انه هو
متميز عنهم اصلا هي هذه الملامح الخارجيه
اللي كانت اللي ينظر الى الان على ان من
علامات الجاذبيه ليتساوي ملامح الوجه كانت
دليل على الصحه في فتره الانسان وكانوا
هؤلاء الاشخاص مطلوبين ومرغبون من الاخرين
لانهم يستطيعوا ان يكونوا مجتمعات اكبر
وينتجوا اطفال اقوال لانه صحتهم افضل لذلك
هم شعره بانهم اعلى درجه من الاخرين
وتعاملوا مع الاخرين من هذا الشيء الغريب
هو رد فعل الاخرين الذين عززوا عندهم هذا
السلوك فاصبحوا نفسهم الجذابون يظنون ان
هذا الشيء حقيقي لانه الاخرين يشاركونهم
فيه اه طب دكتور اسامه يعني باول الحلقه
سهام سالتني سؤال في ما يتعلق بانه هل
الجاذبين اكثر اننيه يوم ما ادرت يعني
تلمس الجواب تبعي شو قصدي انا قلت لها
متفاجئه من هاي الاجابه فيا ريت يا دكتور
تشرح لها انا شو يعني جوابي هذا اولا
ثانيا هل للجاذبين الاكثر انانيا نساء ام
رجال شو رايك بهاي الدراسه مثلا
[ضحك]
انا اعتقد انه رايك صحيح جدا مع الاسف
احنا ننظر الان الى المظاهر الخارجيه وانا
اعتبرها هي المقياس الاكبر لكن هذا ليس
حديث في التاريخ البشري دو- دائما كان
الانسان يبحث عن هذه العلامات ضمن منهن
هذه علامات صحه وهممنا منه المنتشر يكون
صحيح لكن في نفس الوقت مع الاسف الان تحول
الامر الى شيء ذاتي يعني صاروا الاخرين
يجبروا او يحاولوا ان يجبروا المحيطين بهم
ان يقتنعوا انهم جذابون حتى لو كانوا لي
ذلك هل هذه انانيه او هل هذه نوع من
الاوهام بها الاخرون مع الاسف الان بسبب
وسع وهمم واسع ههه
روني اصبح اي والله اليوم جات علي تساعل
فضائل اعلامي اصبح لكل راي ويجب على
الاخرين ان يحترموه يستمعوه حتى لو لم
يكونوا يصدقوه فانتهي نبينا الامر انه
الان احنا مجبرين نصدق انه بعض الاشخاص
جدا حتى لو كانت حالتهم حاله على على الله
يعلمها
ان شاء الله دائما للجاذبيه عنوان وللجمال
عنوان في حياتنا من الرياض الاستشاري
النفسي الدكتور الجميل والجذاب اسامه عامر